مره اخرى يمثل امام قطب القضاء لمكافحه
الارهاب راشد الغنوشي رئيس حركه النهضه
بتهمه جديده تتمثل في استعماله كلمه تاغوت
وهي العباره ذاتها التي كان يستعملها
تنظيم انصار الشريعه الارهابي المحظور في
تونس عندما كان يؤذن احد انصار النهضه
طاغوت التصريح واضح لكن الغنوشي يسر على
ركوب شهوه الهروب الى الامام
استهداف السياسي للمعارضه
ويتم بملفات فارغه لا تثمن ولا تغني من
جوع
الغنوشي متهم ايضا بلقاء عناصر من تنظيم
انصار الشريعه الارهابيه اما المخطط قد
يكشف عنه البحث عند مثوله الخميس المقبل
امام قطب مكافحه الارهاب القضايا المرفوعه
ضد الغنوشي وغيره اعتبر التعافيه للسلطه
القضائيه تعافي القضاء سيفتح بابا لكل
لبحث كل القضايا العالقه وهذا سيحتاج الى
الكثير من الوقت لان القضايا الارهابيه
ليست قضيه سرقه موصوفه يمكن ان يتم بتسب
اثباتها على سارق وبالتالي تحتاج الى وقت
الى الجهد وتشهد تونس موجه ايقافات لعدد
من المتورطين في قضايا فساد وتامر على امن
الدوله تنظر دوائر القضائيه المختصه
في انتظار استكمال تحقيق معه بوصفه
المسؤول الاول عن العشريه السوداء ومهندسه
مارافقها من احداث وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس